[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Under Compute
Engine in the Google
Cloud Platform console, go
to the VM Instances page
and click Create Instance.
Most of the field here
will be pre-populated
in order to speed up
the creation process,
but you're welcome to adjust
anything to suit your needs.
For now, all you'll need
to do is add a name,
and in the Boot
Disk section click
Change to begin
configuring your boot disk.
The first tab is
the OS Images tab.
Here you should choose Debian
9 and then click Select.
In the Firewall section
click Allow HTTP Traffic.
Click Create to
create your instance.
You can check the status
on the VM Instances page.
Once ready, your instance
will be listed here
with a green status icon.
After seeing that icon
next to your instance,
you're ready to connect.
To open a terminal
directly to the instance
you've just created,
click the SSH button.
This will open a new
window and connect.
Congratulations.
You now have a terminal window
for executing shell commands
and interacting directly
with your Linux instance.
Make sure you delete any
instances you don't want to pay
for after this quick start.
[MUSIC PLAYING]